much of the louisiana and mississippi
gulf coast is bracing for what could be
a major hurricane this weekend tropical
storm ida is moving toward the gulf of
mexico and is expected to make landfall
on sunday cbs news meteorologist and
climate specialist jeff beradelli is
tracking what could be a devastating
storm jeff good morning vlad and good
morning everyone this is why i'm so
concerned about this system i think it's
rapidly going to intensify once it's in
the gulf of mexico and it's only two
days from landfall so we have very
little time to prepare storm is getting
better organized right now with
thunderstorms right around its core this
is the official forecast track look at
that a three so a major hurricane is
forecast to impact the southeast
louisiana coast as early as sunday as
you can see now this is why i think
we're going to see rapid intensification
moving over some of the warmest waters
in the gulf of mexico it's likely to
intensify quickly as we head into
saturday and sunday and as it moves
onshore it will likely have wind gusts
over 100 miles an hour and storm surge
forced into the coast of a 7 to 11 feet
so the point is right now you need to
have your supplies and your plan ready
today
all right jeff thank you very much we
appreciate